我正常浪費了20年
而且我敢斷定我們99%的人
也一定會浪費
甚至時間可能還會騙我更長
有人甚至是一輩子
所以我特別想把這條對容分享給大家
如果你更早的
看到這一點的話
可能能少著很多很多的玩路
這條對容
密度會比較高
我會講三部分的那種
然後越往後的那種可能會有用
這個不是話說
就真的是在每個體會
這樣咱們先從第一條
開始和大家分享
就是
我跟我成我的輕人輕力講
然後後面我是怎麼一步一步
這麼做的
我相信很多人都是特別努力的
就是我要學習我的能力
我的氣氛
很多人可能傷了
打學以後
靠研究生
然後靠研的
打各種各樣的徵術
然後殺MBA
對不對
我給大家講的故事
這個故事我之前講過
其實我是在九近年的時候
然後我獨立本書
我是一個特別請問的人
九年我獨立本書
這位書就開始提過
就是講的
畢童開始
那個維吻
是怎麼做的
當時最大的公司
就是維吻
結果我特別受起話
我一看人家變成
然後做這麼大
我就我也可以變成
我不高建築
我就去變成
我去認識我也去認識
通過編成走篩
然後有了這些公司
然後會欺負人員
會欺負人成
然後她說的水平還可以
就是我覺得我已經到了
我天花版的
我腦力挺好的
幾下的
注意不是說我的水平有得高
是到後我來智商的幾下了
可是我差不多工作十多年以後
我才發現
原來是你不是個孩子
政權不是靠編成
不是靠編成
我們認為賺錢
就等你的能力
對不對
實際上要完結
我會去靠編
那麼靠公靠各種
靠各種證書
對吧
各種身在
對不對
其實
賺錢等於什麼
等於能力
成一綱綱
成一歸模
你看我現在做什麼
因為我現在
但是在去聽時候
我還能能力
我在使用綱綱
對不對
比如說是那一綱綱
自然綱綱
就去科技的理解
你看我一使用回來
我使用
對吧
還有一個規模
就是你的用不數
然後你的社群
當你的影響力
對吧
你一定要明白
明白這個道理
所以各位
支付不是靠能力
一定是靠能力
成一你的綱綱
成一你的規模
所以各位
現在你專家的方式
是靠能力嗎
你有沒有綱綱
你有沒有這個規模
對吧
如果沒有
在這點上
一定要
之前好好想一想
這是第一個事情
然後第二件事情
第二件事情
又有一個深度
其實是一個時間為基礎的
這種時間很多
就只舉一個例子的
就是你有沒有發現
真正的問題
不是你能力的
不是你知識的題的
是你的認知
就有問題
就是你的地圖有問題
你拿著就是這個地圖
在新世界行動
我想你之前看
這個欺負你知識的果然
還久平知識的果然
拿著明朝的上方模樣
來清朝
譬如我們好多是這個樣子
就這個世界變化特別快
就是你的認知數問題
都是方向上的錯
你努力
你越努力
你走得越貼
所以
就是說我之前反而不跟大家講
昨晚你的從來不是無知
昨晚你的是什麼
是你救有的管理
而事實上
這就是為什麼
說百分級我是既有的
你都會有問題
因為我們的管理
很多時候都來自由外部的輸入
然後我們這種管理
有的時候就是輸入的
是有的錯的
這個地圖就是錯的
就在對他地圖更新了
所以各位
一定要體會這一點
就是你要學會
在認知上給自己救錯
而不是在
什麼能力
支持上去下努力
看著就話
這話說很多片
可能自殺你的
但事實上你是好事
如果你對這個事的理解是錯
是對的
那麼你走了一定有你想的
東西如果沒有
那就是有個體
對吧
所以各位
一定要學會就說
那我個人怎麼辦
我只要碰到
做出優秀的人
我一定會為問題
大家如果看過我之前的
訪談
我的訪談和別人不太一樣
別人訪談是為了
我訪量是為了做那種
我不是
我是為了改變死的人知
你沒有注意到
我一定會為他們的一個什麼
就是
你能不能跟我們分享一個
就是說我們大多數都這麼認為
就是
但是一張
非常重要非常重要
但是被大多數人
忽略的忽略的忽略的忽略
忽略的忽略的忽略的人知
忽略的人知
忽略問
就說
有沒有那麼一個東西
就是你原來是這麼人為的
但是忽然有一天
因為有什麼事情
你發現這麼人為了
他改變的一生
我最喜歡問的就是
兩個問題
只要做出場面的人
我會問這個問題
我希望各位
也能像成這樣的
一個希望各位
還是那個概念
如果地圖錯
你走得再停的
再努力
把人的做得
這個很能夠抽象
然後我先說
具體點
就是告訴你該怎麼用
你所以認知這個東西
非常非常有用的
包括我上一條視頻
大家有興趣看
他好好看一下上條視頻
包括我最近的視頻
你們一起一看
他吃一點那一塊
我上一條視頻
說你去做一件事情
你做過做的事情
你會發現
發現問題
這個時候就能發現你
認知的問題
那麼你一走
我再以後
你一定會覺得
我靠
是不是
我原來是這麼認為的
但是真實的情況是這樣
我要是找知道多好
有沒有
各位
如果有這種情況
我一定要把他進起來
這才是真正的資產
你千萬不要不要讓他過程
除了對於過程的靈感以後
千萬千萬不要讓他過程
一定要把他做的話
只能過程
這個過程
我再說一點
我原來人類是A
但我後來發現是B
為什麼
什麼樣的事
是這樣
各位有的這個靈感
不管你在幹嘛
一定要把他擊散
文財不重要
文財的東西
只能主要我們思考的速度
所以我跟大家講
文財沒那麼重要的
大部分人來說
就是簡單的
聽說有靈感
無論是劑
哪個比頭也好
讓他允許他來以後
不用考的問題
就把他擊散
就用這個過程
我要來認為A
但
誰一張
這是這句話是B
不要被什麼
如果你做自媒體
我推薦你們做自媒體
我推薦你們習文章
我不解釋別的東西
不是賣貨
不是有多少粉絲
這個不是這個東西很重要
如果你做自媒體
記住
當你有這種動物的時候
你特別興奮的時候
記住不要寫高次
不要寫高次
不重要
有感覺的時候
那記住一塊人看
記住
開頭就怎麼開
我以前認為是這樣的
但他娘的我發現
真實的情況是這樣的
然後為什麼
我給你們講
我做的什麼事
最後怎麼做的那個結果
為什麼
什麼本財結果
不重要
什麼故事
精彩層不重要
你說可怕也不重要
如果說不重要
你只要把這個事
加了我告訴你
這就是這就是一條
包括
你們看我的視頻
就是上千萬的播放
幾乎百分之八十都是這種結果
而且很多時候
我根本就沒搞死
我把排施被沒搞死了
對吧
他就等到為什麼
我告訴你
第一個事情就是
短時間的核心什麼三段
第一塊有用
有用是基礎
第二是情緒
尤其是共鳴
共鳴
挖豪原來
你才會
是不是有各種行為
我們說他多的
怕他不怕他奶奶
他又一講那個
他這個人啥
所以你們能不能一把
他就會給你舊戶
這種舊戶的過程
就會有反規
能挺我的意思
所以情緒
是他的核心
是他的底層
但有用
是基礎
有用才會長遠
還有一個東西
就是對我考慮
他是這樣
短時間是這三項
所以
你說
我原來認為是這樣的
後來你聽
原來你一人
我考慮
我也犯了這個錯
但是我發現是
他的這次新聞是這樣的
可動機發人對我
這個
這個才是真正高級的動機
你知道嗎
你給大家講
我到底是怎麼做的
這就是有用的
這種視頻
天然就是
就是身體
你能替我吧
所以什麼本來
還能到一邊去吧
所以各位
今天呢
我就希望你想幾個問題
所以第一個問題
就是你現在做的這個事情
是你考慮能力的事情
還是已經有的尷尬
然後有了會如果沒有
把它放進去的計劃
只是方向
遇到一個真正
你佩服的記者
問他那個問題
你有那些
就你認為很重要
但是被我們這些人
大部分人都忽略的人質
忽略的人質
有沒有那麼一個是你人
但是這麼人類的
後來發現
現在是這樣
然後的人生發了那邊
就問這個問題
他能幫你少主管
如果叫他認知
就做本來
然後第三個
一旦你應有了
有了這種靈感的時候
所以是把的計劃
去世是什麼
我認為是
誒
方向已經中卻
方向錯了
努力白費